hey guys it is the 13th of August today
my name is just McDonald and here's some
of the things that mattered in gaming
today a new star wars battlefront mode
with announced today and it's where you
can play the game's biggest Matt
supremacy mode is a control points mode
where each team starts with their own
pair of control points and must fight
for ownership of a central neutral point
then they'll have to capture all five or
hold the majority of the points for 10
minutes unlike battlefields conquest
mode which is very similar points must
be captured in order and only two were
active at any given time so you can't
run off to grab the one that no one's
guarding this is to ensure the action
today centralized and players won't feel
isolated from the fight supremacy is set
to feature massive maps vehicles and
famous heroes and villains from the Star
Wars universe including Vader Skywalker
and / Fett EA has weighed in on the
Kajima and Konami drama with co o Peter
Moore saying that the two should kiss
and make up gamespot asked Peter Moore
if he was keen on signing kijima to
which he replied I've always liked
kajima son I got on with him during my
days at Microsoft I just think what's
going on there I just think both of them
should kiss and make up from my
experience and I've spent a lot of time
working in Japan I think that Konami and
kajima we'll figure it out those kinds
of business relationships in Japan are
typically for life and kajima is such an
important part of what's gone on there
more said ëi wouldn't be aggressively
poaching he talent like kajima although
over the last year the company have
hired veteran uncharted writer Amy
Hennig and Assassin's Creed co-creator
Jade Raymond Eurogamer asked Xbox
bosqueville Spencer how he planned to
catch up with Sony in the console race
and he didn't seem too worried about it
Spencer said Sony earned the success
with the ps4 and all he can do is focus
on xbox he explained we're seeing more
people online more games being sold more
consoles being sold so generally I
good about the trajectory we're on ads
for improvements Spencer said that
microsoft needs to improve Xbox one
sales in Central Europe where it hasn't
been doing particularly well as far as
competing with Sony go Spencer explained
I honestly don't goal the team on how
many units thrown yourself Spencer went
on to further stress the company's
investment in first party projects and
emphasize how they're crucial for
achieving xboxes long-term goals let me
know down in that comment section if you
reckon kijima and Konami still have a
chance to mend fences or not and why you
can add the game slaughter we've got
stories on fallout shelters coming to
android and dying light sales that is
everything I wanted to tell you about
today be sure to join me same time
tomorrow for the best five stories of
the whole gaming week I'll catch you
then